i was probably one of the sickest that
they've had coming through the hospital
in 2017 i got to represent my country in
in both wheelchair rugby league and in
milwaukee tennis i still pinch myself
with the opportunity every day
i'm stefan i'm 26 years old and i was
born with spina bifida
[Music]
so spina bifida it's a skeletal birth
defect
doctors said basically i wouldn't have
any chance of living past 24 hours
because i was just too sick when i was
born i had the head size of jimmy
neutron basically
your body i think naturally will drain
out brain fluid from your head um and
throughout your body and so
unfortunately that's what my body can't
do and so that's why i've got the
machine the chunk put into my head
i can have a lot of impacts for me
personally i can feel my body right on
through to my ankles and unfortunately i
can't feel my feet i'm a part-time
walker if you want to call it that i can
walk short distances
[Music]
in high school i didn't feel comfortable
very much in my own skin
it was all about trying to fit into the
best of my ability and i really thought
to myself you know i'm really different
like
my upper body is growing the way that it
should but unfortunately my legs are
still looking like cricket stumps
growing up as a kid i was always kicking
around with the footy and everything
like that i'm on a huge west tigers fair
you know as i got older and understood
the severity of my disability i knew
that that dream was was starting to
really get further and further away from
me
so that's when i at the age of 12
decided to pick up wheelchair tennis to
at least give some sort of hope of
becoming an athlete
[Music]
i was asked
quite a few insensitive questions in
high school and you know every single
time that you know i'd be associated
with getting a girlfriend or anything
like that my peers around me would
always say you know are they are they
also in a wheelchair are they disabled
as well and so that's where i kind of
really thought to myself no like people
with a disability can be in mainstream
relationships as well and
i i really took offense to it at the
time
i guess the negative kind of thoughts at
that time really took over me and really
swamped me and the conversations i was
having with myself was you know
mate you're a piece of [ __ ]
i was i was stuck in that cycle for i'd
say a good three years
the turning point definitely for me was
having a conversation with my tennis
coach we talked about what what's going
on how i viewed myself my value to
myself
how i thought my value was to the people
around me
[Music]
my tennis coach had exposed me to a
simple exercise really which is two
things that you're grateful for and one
thing you found challenging throughout
your day
that for me was was the real kicker
it's definitely helped my mental state
in terms of understanding myself better
and understanding my limitations as an
individual both physically and mentally
and what i can look to aspire to be like
[Music]
wheelchair rugby league it was just a
thing that just came about for me in
2013 and i was always looking for the
opportunity
it's a bit like austin but in a
wheelchair but it still doesn't
obviously stop you from smashing into
someone and having them
fall to the ground
it's a sport that is inclusive so you
don't actually need to have a disability
to actually play the sport which is the
best thing wheelchair rugby league has
especially made me feel like i belong
because i guess it's it's the closest
thing
with our able-bodied counterparts that
we can actually be a part of so
i'm always being included in nrl things
and i'm able to be surrounded by
all the people that i idolized growing
up
in 2017 i got to represent my country in
in both wheelchair rugby league and in
milwaukee tennis and i couldn't have
been any prouder for that year to have
occurred
[Music]
i've also kick-started up a modelling
career i really wanted to start that
primarily because of you know how
i viewed myself growing up as an
individual
and i really wanted to recreate the
narrative of how the industry really
says models where you know they have to
be six foot tall and
tall skinny and all these sorts of
things that a lot of people can't aspire
to be like and so that's where i really
want to be able to start those
conversations of having disabled models
be more featured in mainstream
advertisements
i was very single for a long time to the
point where i was making dinner for two
and eating both
[Music]
brooke is amazing how she has picked up
the perspective of me living with a
disability and
and and how she's able to to aid me and
still be able to give me the sense of
independence that i still crave as an
individual living with a disability is
something that you know i love to have
and um she compliments me again so well
apart from the fact you go for granola
baby
we always tend to have the one or two
people that kind of look at us where
it's like you know
is that
who he's dating and i always have sort
of grin on my face thinking yeah that's
who i'm dating that's not my carer
that's my girlfriend i love you babe
[Laughter]
[Music]
i definitely feel like there is a
silence
and how we how we disrupt that
is by speaking about it more
whether that be through
dinner talks or
you know whether or not we see someone
on the street and just having a general
conversation about that i feel that if
we have
more normality around
conversations of disability in open
spaces especially i think that's when we
can really start to change the narrative
of mental health and disabled people
going hand in hand with each other
[Music]
if anything of what i've said has hit
home for you
click on to any of these organizations
here and seek help today